[Musique]
de quelle légitimité suivi si bien y en
a une qui va vous faire rire
je suis celui qui a inauguré cette salle
pour en faire une salle de théâtre en
j'avais commis une pièce réunit une
équipe une compagnie ait demandé à paul
puaux où j'aurais pu la jouer c'était
les débuts du off 44 ans avant et il m'a
dit tiens va voir va voir l'évêché il ya
une salle paroissiale et c'était la
salle benoît xii
elle ressemblait pas du tout à ce qui
est ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui il y
avait une mezzanine y avait un parterre
avec des fautes des sièges en bois qui
claquait c'était une salle de patronage
y avait un cadre d'un cadran dur c'était
vraiment vraiment une cité pas une très
bonne salle pour tout vous dire
mais l'expérience a été très positive et
a permis à puyoô ensuite de se tourner
vers la ville pour racheter cette salade
évêché et en faire la sale que vous avez
que ça dans laquelle vous êtes assise
aujourd'hui pour moi c'est donc la
boucle semble non pas se refermer parce
que j'espère bien qu'elles se referment
pas ce soir mais en tout cas c'est voilà
j'étais sur cette scène il ya 44 ans et
j ce soir l'autre légitimité l'autre
petit point d'inflexion petit nom énorme
c'est que dans ma vie j'ai eu la chance
et le bonheur de rencontrer une jeune
femme s'appelait dominique villars et la
fille de jean que j'ai donc très bien
connu malheureusement dominé est décédé
à ces jeunes à 50 ans et j'ai gardé avec
cette famille les liens les plus étroits
d'affection et d'amitié
c'est à ce titre que plus haut après son
décès c'est pas lui qui s'est tourné
vers moi après son décès mais enfin
c'est le conseil d'administration du 20
janvier l'art qui m'a demandé de prendre
la direction de cette maison en 2003 et
je les quitte et il y a maintenant une
toute petite année pour la laisser à une
nouvelle direction
une nouvelle directrice et j'en suis
très heureux on en parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure voilà les deux raisons
pour lesquelles il semblerait que je
connaisse quelque chose à ces
territoires et ligne année mais très
modestement je pense que il faut
peut-être commencer par faire un peu
d'histoire
certains d'entre vous connaissent cette
histoire par coeur mais enfin la
pédagogie par la répétition je répète
1947 jean vilar ne crée pas le festival
d'avignon
ce sont deux marchands d'art christian
ivan zervos qui ont l'idée d'amener ici
la collection des peintres qu'ils ont
sous leur égide
c'est pas être sont peu connus ils ne
sont pas encore les stars qui vont être
ils vont devenir
ils sont picasso matisse braque léger
voilà mais ils ne sont pas plus connu
que ne seront connues les comédiens de
janvier l'art quelques années plus tard
les jeanne moreau à part jura flip qui
était connu les joies de mon rôle et
philippe noiret ne sont pas connus quand
ils vont à rio c'est là mêmes propos que
la même relation
l'autre chose tout à fait extraordinaire
de la part des cerveaux c'est de venir à
avignon a porté ses grands peintres qui
sont aujourd'hui au centre pompidou à
beaubourg pour à l'époque venir à
avignon présenter ses oeuvres
c'était aller en afrique rappelez-vous
que malraux parler de l'odieux mots de
province contre lequel il fallait
évidemment lutté près dé 0 6 lits à un
aspirateur un homme qui s'appelle rhin
et chats qui se dit que l'art
contemporain ce n'est pas simplement les
plasticiens c'est aussi éventuellement
le théâtre la musique il y aura donc du
théâtre et de la musique alignons et il
se tourne vers un jeune metteur en scène
qui vient de passer le nez à la fenêtre
comme ça et d'avoir un gros succès avec
le avec une pièce qui s'intitule meurtre
dans la cathédrale dont il demande à
villars de venir jouer dans la cour
d'honneur le meurtre dans la cathédrale
ça fait un peu plein au pléonasme
voyez-vous parce que meurent dans la
cathédrale évidemment l'histoire d'un
archevêque assassiné par un roi et la
palais le palais des papes tout va bien
ça colle ensemble et c'est là que
villard à sa première idée at première
intuition géniale c'est de refuser et de
revenir vingt jours après qu'un jour
après auprès de ses amis zervos chars
voir le maire d'avignon aussi monsieur
le docteur pons faut leur dire écoutez
j'ai une autre idée on va je vais venir
à avignon avec trois spectacles donc un
shakespeare vous avez aperçu un
shakespeare un claudel est une oeuvre
contemporaine dans trois lieux
différents
c'est très acteur très important que je
vois que je vous rappelle ça car dès
l'origine jean vilar à penser ce
festival
non pas comme un fait
qui va le présentant des oeuvres non
dont il s'agit de prendre d'assaut une
ville et de mettre une ville en festival
n'est ce pas comme on entre en religion
3il trois lieux différents cour
d'honneur vergeer urbain 5 et théâtre
municipal qui sont donc les prémices de
ce que deviendra le festival dans les
années qui suivront dans une lettre
qu'il écrit à sa dinde son
administratrice à la fin de ce festival
il lui dit il faudrait que l'an prochain
des metteurs en scène s'occupe des
oeuvres moi je m'occuperai de tous ces
gens dans les cours 47
on dirait qu'ils voient le off et je
peux vous dire que cette mise en scène
sera supérieure à la précédente ce qui
m'a toujours c'est dire que villard
était davantage un metteur en scène du
public
c'est un grand artiste mais d'abord à
mettre en scène du public donc le voici
dans la cour d'honneur très beau lieu
qui réuni 2500 spectateurs
ses 2500 spectateurs ne sont pas 2500
dès le premier jour mais petit à petit
l'oiseau fait son nid et comme il
réussit on lui propose à paris je passe
sur les détails de la personnalité très
importante de jeunes laurent qui va
demander à jean vilar de s'installer à
chaillot à chaillot dont voici la salle
épouvantable 2006 en place également
villard découvre dans l'est dans les
caves du palais chaillot autrement dit
dans les oublis de chaillot qu'il y
avait là un théâtre qui s'appelait le
théâtre national populaire et il va
ressortir ces trois lettres pour en
faire un futur helmand le fleuron de ce
que sera le théâtre populaire de la fin
du siècle dernier dans ses deux salles
marche sur deux pieds n'est ce pas à
jean dion dans ces deux palais avignon
et palais de chaillot villard va réunir
un énorme public encore une fois de 2500
places environ 500 mille spectateurs par
an au bout de son aventure il réunira
cinq millions et demi de spectateurs
c'est absolument considérable et
répondre donc à la question du
territoire avec jean vila sait répondre
par le mot public la question du public
c'est la réponse de villars à la
question du territoire d'aujourd'hui
mais quel public
villard employer un mot habituellement
d'abord villard s'adresse à tous ça
c'est clair
il a une démarche universelle mais il
s'adresse bien sûr aux avignonnais mais
des avignonnais ou des parisiens ou ou
de la nation il va s'adresser tout
particulièrement à ce qu'il appelle ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque les classes
laborieuses dans ce mot on n'entend
évidemment un mot un peu communisants un
vocabulaire une idéologie un peu suranné
certes et lila n'étais pas communiste
loin de là mais sachez je le tiens de sa
bouche que il a connu au début de la
guerre et dans son jeune âge donc 28 30
ans la plus grande misère c'est un homme
qui a qui a souffert de malnutrition qui
a fréquenté les soupes populaires qui a
connu le pain noir
il mangeait des croûtons de croûtons de
pain dur dans des fonds moutarde
il sera d'ailleurs il sera très malades
des suites de serait de ce type de
régime
bref il considère qu'il a fait partie
des misérables cher à victor hugo ce qui
lui permettra de refuser des leçons de
morale et de bienséance de la gauche
bien pensante quand plus tard elle
viendra l'embêter en particulier en 68
avec cette révolution qui est venu
bousculer janvier dans son festival donc
villard apprend quoi dans ces années là
il apprend qu on ne veut pas un conte ne
meurt pas que de fin on meurt aussi
d'ignorance on meurt aussi d'être privés
du divertissement et de la connaissance
est le digne du divertissement car
dinars est un homme sérieux grave juste
un homme qui aime s'amuser et il pense
que le plaisir est un arm une arme
essentielle évidemment au bout de la
culture et souvenez-vous que molière
disait il s'agit de plaire est touché
donc comment fait-on ben voilà donc on
est dans la danse est question de ces
classes laborieuses comment fait-on pour
les toucher on est revenons à notre
histoire
revenons à la grèce le théâtre est né en
2005 de 1500 ans avant le nôtre avant
notre ère en grèce et c'est le premier
acte de la démocratie comme vous le
savez il s'agissait de réunir dans de
très grandes races assemblée c'est une
question ça c'est du talent de masse
devant des assemblées de huit à dix
mille personnes on se réunit autour des
dieux autour des mythes autour
l'identité nationale bien sûr et c'est
là que l'on apprend par sophocle par
euripide c'est qu'on en apprend qu'il en
est et comment on se soigne et comment
on passe à la catharsis bien sûr voyez
ça c'est là c'est donc le théâtre
partagé pour tous le théâtre qui réunit
le théâtre unanime le temps passe le
théâtre quitte ses racines religieuses
les gardes jusqu'au moyen-âge et puis
entre dans le monde du capitalisme qui
commencent à conquérir le monde jusqu'à
nos jours
et là arrive les industries culturelles
je pense que la lutte de vina au
festival d'avignon dès qu' il a il a mis
les pieds dans avignon c'est de dire il
faut échapper à cette inde russie
industrialisation de la culture à cette
financiarisation pour rester
désintéressé et pour échapper aux lois
du marché
à la même époque le festival de cannes
et n'est en 47 également avec une palme
villa refusera les palmes bien sûr il
recevra la légion d'honneur je vous le
signale et il fera en sorte que jamais
le festival d'avignon ne soit un
concours d'ailleurs le mot festival lui
a été imposée par mot valise si vous
voulez il aurait préféré que cela sape
la rencontre rencontre d'avignon
comment fait-il donc si le ce défi de
villars comment va-t-il de réaliser il
ya avec une équipe administrative c'est
génial
piloté par jean prouvé il va organiser
mettre en place un dispositif dispositif
d'accès à la culture qui est le fait de
parler aux gens et de leur permettre de
comprendre d'éclairer quand je dis le
mot éclairé c'est pas éclairé éclairer
le chemin un phare n'éclaire pas la
route phare indique l'écueil dont il
s'agit de rendre clair les difficultés
de rendre clair les oeuvres et de non
pas les les ans les enfermer dans
voilà dans un appareil qui seraient
exclues en alors avec cette équipe
administrative
il va inventer un abonnement il va
avancer l'heure des spectacles de
bonheur pour éviter de se coucher trop
tard
il va supprimer le pourboire un
pourboire c'est une humiliation il faut
tendre la main et moi qui dois donner
cette aumône jeune emilie en l'acceptant
le vestiaire sera gratuit je
distribuerai à la sortie ou pendant le
spectacle enfin à l'entracte le texte de
la pièce un tarif absolument abordable
c'est l'équivalent d'un euro
d'aujourd'hui il va s'en vendre près
d'un million et demi de toutes les pieds
de tout les doutes les oeuvres jouées
par le tnt
voyez il ya toute une série comme ça
l'accueil en musique
je prends même que j'ai une très jolie
image de la cage de musique on reviendra
sur cette belle photo d'avant vous avez
vu jean vilar par les assauts à ce
peuple c'est éclaireurs n'est ce pas et
c'est ainsi que le festival d'avignon et
chaillot vont élargir le cercle de ces
connaisseurs ville à s'adresser dans son
temps dans ces années 47 à 60 à un
public
aujourd'hui il y à des publics alors
évidemment tout a changé et revenons à
avignon je pense que l'étude de ce
territoire est très intéressante du
point de vue artistique politique
sociale et géographique etc
nous avons un villar qui va agir dans
une ville de 40000 habitants intra muros
moi j'ai été un peu enfant ici dans la
région je me souviens d'une ville très
active de dix artisans où il y avait
c'était une fourmilière
elle ressemble à avignon l'été la mama
ville des années 50 c'est avignon l'été
d'aujourd'hui ça a tout changé et bien
sûr la dila exploser ses vêtements des
autotours et nous sommes nous sommes
sortis donc d'un public univoque
j'aime à dire un public à des publics
équivoque
ils ont plusieurs voix alors comment
résoudre ces grandes contradictions
d'aujourd'hui les deux grands artisans
de cette résolution éventuelle c'est
évidemment d'un côté la ville et ses
édiles et ses élus et là je n'entre pas
du tout
ma politique quel qu'il soit mais en
tout cas leur responsabilité qui est
celle de la de la fluidité des
circulations de l'ordre évidemment de la
paix mais aussi du bonheur et du confort
urbain
mais est ce que le théâtre est quelque
chose qui doit appartenir au confort
urbain
c'est une des revendications le théâtre
et l'action culturelle à se veulent
quand même plus subversive que
simplement satisfaire des besoins
immédiats
1 c'est pas tout à fait la même chose et
bien effectivement ce festival
je voudrais attirer votre attention sur
une chose jean vilar et donc à chaillot
et avignon jusqu'en 1963 date à laquelle
il quitte le tnp et non seulement il
quitte le tnp mais il renonce à
continuer de faire l'artiste de faire la
metteur en scène et de faire le comédien
il le fera occasionnellement au cinéma
un petit peu au théâtre privé d'ailleurs
un petit peu à l'opéra mais en fait il a
fini et il va s'occuper de son oeuvre et
son oeuvre c'est quoi c'est ici c'est le
festival d'avignon et il lit très
joliment je me suis longtemps dans ma
vie occupé de la scène des arts de la
scène
un jour j'ai levé le nez et j'ai trouvé
puisqu'il se passait autour étaient
beaucoup plus intéressant c'est
exactement je crois c'est ce mot qu'il
faut que vous gardiez que nous gardions
dans l'aventuré du festival d'avignon
d'hier d'aujourd'hui et de demain
avignon est une ville très compliqué
très très très compliqué c'est une ville
d'obstacles j'ai vécu dans cette maison
jean vilar que vous connaissez derrière
mais au mur qui sont eux-mêmes derrière
des remparts et derrière les remparts il
ya le rempart du fleuve puis le rempart
de la voie ferrée puis le rempart de la
rocade puis le rencard de la stature
verte
nous sommes dans des cercles comme ça
qu'ils n'ont pas concentriques mitis oui
ils sont concentrés mais qui s'éloignent
les uns des autres ils font que les
publics les publics s'éloignent les uns
des autres
qu'ont de commun les gens de champ
fleuri et les gens de la de la reine
jeanne
ils se connaissent même pas donc eux est
alors avec d'intramuros encore moins
donc vous voyez ces contradictions sont
extraordinairement difficile
à résoudre et d'ailleurs sont-elles
raisonnable je n'en sais strictement
rien étant donné que je ne me mêle pas
heureusement pour moi de se produire des
grands problèmes d'urbanisme
mais enfin vous voyez que la présence du
festival se définit à ce moment a
complètement comme un festival
éminemment politique pas politicien
politique c'est à dire qu'il ya une
responsabilité civique une
responsabilité sociale des artistes
c'est un débat qui agite beaucoup les
artistes est ce qu'on fait de du jeu
sochaux plus du culturel social ou est
ce qu on fait de l'art ce débat était
très très prenant du temps de la
direction de vincent baudriller et
hortense archambault où il y avait des
artistes très contemporain qui n'étaient
pas dans le souci du public
et vous vous souvenez que ça avait ça
avait pas mal fait crier donc festival
de contestation festival dorée de
réflexion mais et pourquoi pourquoi ces
festivals gêne-t-il dès 1954 jean vila a
failli être viré pas un complot de
notables qui aurait préféré voir des
norias de rolls royce avait des tapis
rouge le long du festival du palais des
papes pour aller applaudir les ballets
du marquis de cuevas ou un festival de
cannes quelconque plutôt que 1 gérard
philipe dans le cid le cilss et scolaire
voyez il n'en voulait plus comment a
t'il vaincue 7-6 7
ce croc en jambe par une pétition de 24
mille signatures qui ont demandé à la
ville de garder jean vila au pouvoir sur
40000 personnes voyez c'est un phénomène
tout à fait extraordinaire qui me fait
dire que le paysan du vaucluse où le
prolétaire de paris n'allez peut-être
pas à chaillot au palais des papes
mais il savait qu'il pouvait y aller je
voulais cette réflexion elle et elle et
elle est très excusez moi elle est très
près pas de moi 2,46 qui dirige le tnt
actuellement à lyon
elle est très profonde ils savaient
qu'ils pouvaient même si vous n'y allez
pas je sais que je peux y aller et ça
c'est un problème de communication qui
me paraît essentiel dans la le partage
de la culture et l'abord de la culture
bien sûr en 68 vous le sou vous souvenez
vous le savez bien sûr villa a été
bousculé et insulté mais le festival a
eu lieu il a maintenu son festival hors
d'eau et c'est lily allen qui a gagné
contre les bourgeois nantis qui venait
l'accusé de ne pas faire une culture
populaire ce qui l'avait fait pendant
tant d'années
donc c'est ça a été évidemment un moment
extraordinairement dramatiques sur
lequel il a laissé sans doute beaucoup
de sa santé puisqu'il est mort trois
quatre ans après en 2003 ce festival est
annulé
moi je prétends qu'il n'est pas annulée
je prétends qu'il a eu lieu il a été
annulé parce que les spectacles n'ont
pas eu lieu mais le festival a lieu il
ya eu lieu c'est une sorte de conférence
ouvrière pendant un mois de grève ou les
intermittents étaient le symptôme d'une
crise sociale nationale et c'est ici que
ça s'est passé ça s'est passé ailleurs
et cette spécificité avignonnaise je
crois qu'il faut que nous en soyons
fiers et que nous continuons de la
défendre bec et ongles car nous sommes
dans un rendez-vous de la pensée donc je
pense que villard était une sorte de
président de la république du théâtre et
de l'action culturelle en général
souvenez-vous que du 5 juillet au 28
août environ 20 25 mille personnes
entrent et sortent de cette ville tous
les jours c'est une bombe sociétale qui
nous arrive qui vient dans cette ville
bond économique
les bombes de la pensée aussi mes
petites cousines et qui tenait ce pardon
qui sont venus l'été dernier mon 10
était merveilleuse ont passé trois jours
qu'est ce que vous avez vu rien
c'était merveilleux pourquoi le débat ce
qui se passe un peu ici c'est un peu un
peu la même chose et 7,7 cette chose je
dirais non pas à la bonne franquette
parce que c'est très exigeant mais en
tout cas de bon aloi et où on est
accueilli et non pas exclue donc notre
territoire
à mes yeux est toujours dépassé et tant
mieux c'est ce dépassement qu'il faut
que nous assumions il est dépassé par il
faut entrer dans les territoires de
l'intelligence il ne faut pas avoir peur
du mot intelligence ce n'est pas un
monde ardue ce n'est pas une
on n'exclut pas au contraire vous êtes
intelligent c'est ça qui disait ville
arras et à son public qui souvent dix
ans mais vous savez moi je sais pas mais
non vous êtes riche de
vos vies vous êtes donc aussi riche que
moi c'est votre vie qui compte ça c'est
votre culture donc liberté élévation
j'aime beaucoup ce mot d'un comédien qui
disait ce petit homme n'était pas très
grands vilains vous oblige à vous tenir
droit voilà élargir le cercle des
connaisseurs ça c'est un mot de brecht
que villard aurait bien pris et moi
j'aime bien dire que l'utopie de jean
vila est armé d'une spiritualité laïque
essayé d'approfondir avec moi ces mots
tout à l'heure séparément spiritualité
laïque loyer pour réenchanter une
univers voilà matérialiste et qui auquel
nous sommes parfois obligés de venir
c'est pour ça que je dirais non sans
rire que l'on sent sourire en tout cas
que gillard est en quelque sorte le
dixième papes d'avignon
naguère il ya pas longtemps fire
quelques années il y avait un slogan
avignon ville d'esprit je ne sais pas
pourquoi ça a été bien pourquoi en avant
l'utilisent plus pour moi a dit niant
lille d'esprit avignon ville ouverte
sont les mots d'ordre et de conviction
qui sont absolument nécessaires à la
conquête de notre territoire
merci
[Applaudissements]